نقف الان داخل غرفه اداره العمليات
والازمات في افاد اي اداره الطوارئ
والكوارث في انقره حيث يدير المسؤولون
كافه العمليات الخاصه
بالتنسيق ومعالجه تبعات هذا الزلزال
وتامين وصول فرق الانقاذ الى الاماكن
المنكوبه تشاهدون هنا ممثلون عن 25 وزاره
ومؤسسه حكوميه وغير حكوميه هؤلاء الاشخاص
هم على صله بالتعامل مع الازمات من
مؤسساتهم وزير الخارجيه
يتواجد في مركز افاد الان لكي ينسق وصول
المساعدات الخارجيه يبلغ مركز افاد
بالطلبات التي تاتي من الدول الثانيه
ويؤمن وصولها
المناطق المنكوبه هناك رقم اخر للاشخاص
المتواجدين في المناطق
المنكوبه يقدمون لافاد بلاغات حول
الاحتياجات حول طبيعه المساعدات التي
يريدونها هؤلاء الاشخاص او المسؤولون من
المؤسسات المعنيه يقومون بتسجيل هذه
الطلبات التنسيق
وارسالها الى المناطق المنكوبه اذا غرفه
العمليات هذه تدور فيها عمليه معقده
للغايه من هذا المكان يتم اصدار التعليمات
حول كيفيه
ذهاب الطواقم حول كيفيه تامين المساعدات
وايضا يتم الاعلان عن اخر الارقام والخاصه
بحصيله القتلى والجرحى المباني المتضرره
من خلال تلقي اتصالات من داخل الميدان من
المناطق المتضررات فرح زمن شوقي من داخل
غرفه العمليات في هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث
في انقره